yeah it's coming our Christmas
correspondent Jimmy FAA just can't
contain his excitement Jimmy where are
you there I am and I am standing by with
Chief belucci from the Port Authority
police department does New York love its
men and women in uniform or
what you're damn right it does now Chief
I got to be upfront with you I would
have been a cop if it weren't for this
thing called a background check but you
guys you passed it and you represent our
city every day Santa comes once a year
you guys show up 365 do you feel the
love from this city oh no doubt
tonight's a great night we really
appreciate that and we wish everybody a
happy and safe holiday from the P author
police but knowing Santa gets cookies
and milk for one night of work do you
guys deserve cookies and milk what
should we be doing here uh n give them
to the kids we're good you say give them
to the kids the the chief says the kids
can have the cookies do you hear me
kids notice how we offered them to the
kids and not not me he's like look chubs
you're on TV I don't appreciate that
Chief all right I've had enough Harold
we're coming to you well is it time to
light the All-American Christmas tree
yet yes it really is the time we've all
been waiting for we're lighting up the
All-American tree our co-host and my
friend Jessica toover is here too
because she didn't want to miss the big
moment we got two of us around the table
Jessica yeah Jesse all right before we
push that big button all the kids in the
audience I want want you guys to come up
onto the stage you are so we can get a
nice view hi I said Jimmy the kids not
you yeah Jimmy stay over there as far
away from the kids as okay but but the
thing is where's the kids kids get up
here okay wait kids I think we are
missing
something santa santa
[Applause]
santa santa santa over there over there
I think we see him yeah he's stuck in
traffic I think he's coming hold on just
keep looking that
way here yay here he comes Merry
[Applause]
Christmas how are you Merry Christmas
everyone how are you he's coming so good
to see all of you oh wow this is
wonderful hi guys how are
you here he is good to see you s you
like me to come up there I would glad to
I can do that welcome welcome who are
you young
man I thought they all like their
parents that's right that's right well
happy to have you here Santa all right
is everybody ready to light the All
American
Tree are you count it down with me 10 n
8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 Merry Christmas Merry
[Applause]
Christmas
going to your
[Music]
hair a lot of love to go around but
that's what giving is about too giving
and taking care of others the love that
we bring to
others you're a beautiful Santa thank
you you're a goodl looking Santa
special I mean that's that's the cutest
Santa I ever saw Jacob what do you
think I know you don't know but you're
happy all it is beautiful it's a almost
as tall
as which is what button for that one it
turned on it turned on the tree
[Music]
JJ what do you think well Merry
Christmas everyone come by the fox
Christmas tree it's been a treat for us
to be with all of you that is going to
be it for us have a great night and a
Merry Christ Christmas Merry Christmas
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else